the book is out today so after 60
episodes of my book series I can finally
talk to you about what the book is about
and announce the pre-orders for it today
so the book is called your one word and
what it does is document the journey
that I took define my one word of
believe and also help you live a life on
purpose as well as building a business
on purpose what I believe is that
everybody has one word that defines them
it's who you have always been and who
you always will be and people most
people live mediocre life most people
live a life that is not done on intent
it's just constantly reacting to other
things that are happening and when you
understand what you're all about and who
you truly are it allows you to then
design a life and design a business that
supports you becoming the best version
of yourself it starts with me not being
happy in my business not being happy
with where it was going not feeling like
I was doing enough big enough stuff
being frustrated that you know I'm
making content just to try to make
advertising knowledge but it wasn't
truly fulfilling and so I thought it was
a problem of just my hashtag in my my
slogan I thought okay if I change it to
you know entrepreneurs deserve help or
20 entrepreneurs you know 20 million
entrepreneurs helped and Counting and
just didn't feel right and so what ended
up happening was I made a list of all
the things that I felt that were
important to me and believed was on that
list and I thought it was too big a word
I thought too many people had used it
before I thought it was not descriptive
enough of what I was doing but the more
I looked at it the more I felt like this
really kind of describes who I have
always been my parents always believed
in me my favorite movie growing up with
Seabiscuit which is about this horse
that is an underdog that nobody believes
in and ends up winning the songs and I
like or about believe the books that I
like about believe and it's been always
who I have been in it what I am meeting
with entrepreneurs are helping people
and believing in them that's what really
fires me up in nooks become alive and I
built a business around it but at the
very start I wasn't so sure it sounded
like this big scary project and so I
started with my newsletter and I made
one newsletter that I sent out
that was talking about believe in the
new campaign and the first person right
back was my sister who said that she
liked it and she's actually going to
read my newsletters now so thank you
Stefan for that one but that one news
that I already had fifty percent more
engagement than any of my other
newsletter so it's on the right track
then I made a youtube video called
believe and previously my best video had
a hundred thousand views in a year and
this video did a hundred thousand views
in a month so just insane about the
impact that it had and then I thought
you know what I'm gonna do this crazy
thing and brand my entire business
around believe and I changed my logo
when I create a t-shirts and you know
put videos out and change my website
around and everything that I did now I
saw through the lens of belief and it's
had a tremendous impact on the growth if
you look at my youtube channel go back
and see the trajectory a lot of the
massive growth came when I changed
everything around believe and so I think
a lot of people don't really have the
self-awareness don't really know what
they stand for don't really know who
they are and that's that sucks because
your one word is a thing is the filter
that you see the world through your one
work and help with all the major
important decisions that you have to
make in your life and in your business
and so what the book does is help you
figure out what it is that you staying
for and then how to apply that in your
life but mostly on your business so it
starts with core moves the campaign and
then goes to company and in core gives
you all the exercises that you need to
figure out who you are what you stand
for what's the most important thing to
you in campaign we start talking about
okay how do I apply that to a business
setting how do I apply that to make
money so you know great I care about
believer I care about calm or I care
about family right if you look at TDS
Turner that's also family is our one
word you know I care about these things
how do I make money off of that what are
the things that you have to go through
what's the checklist and then section 3
is about building a company so not just
having a marketing campaign but
everything right how I hire is through
believe right how I raise capitals
through believe how I run my operations
is through belief and it tells my story
it tells Sheamus on trip renew his story
and it also brings you along the journey
of five different entrepreneurs who've
achieved various levels of success so
the first guy has made fifty thousand
dollars as a full-time entrepreneur now
from his hobby that is built around the
business now around his
one word the second was actually trying
to dance also that became a half million
dollar business around the one word of
family the third one is a guy who's
built the video production company
that's over a million dollars around his
one word the fourth one is a company
that's built over five million dollar
business around there one word and the
fifth one is the company is built over
150 million dollar business around there
one word and so no matter where you are
at the stage if you're just starting up
when like fifty thousand dollars a year
is something that's interesting to you
then there's stories for you to follow
if you've already done that and you want
to build the five million other business
or 150 million royal business there's
people who've done that for you and all
along the way I wish somebody had given
me the roadmap I wish he didn't have to
write this book I wish that I could just
read it and apply it but because it
didn't exist I went out and interviewed
all these people who have done it and
they've all just kind of figured it out
on their own and now we've actually
created the book to be able to help you
go out and do it have a meaningful
impact on your life change the way you
think hopefully challenge you to want to
do something bigger a lot of people go
through the exercises and realize i'm
not actually living the life that I'm
supposed to live and that is a sometimes
big and very painful realization and
then from there it's okay what steps are
going to take to actually build
something purposeful with meaning and it
takes you through the step-by-step
process I had to do that so I'm so
excited the book has gone out to 20
different people and it's been amazing
to see the impact that has already had
on their lives and I'm so excited to get
it into the hands of you guys people
start making changes and what you're all
about so tied to it is the launch page
I'll link it up here in the description
in the video you can check it out
there's a bunch of different bonus
packages tons of different bonuses at
different levels and hopefully you guys
will support me on my journey if you've
gotten value from the videos that I
putting out but really appreciate your
support there but also super excited to
see you read it and apply it the book
comes out december six so we still have
a long ways away for that but the
bonuses will start to happen right away
so if you guys order within the next
week those were nurses will come to you
and they'll be changed to be featured on
the youtube channel a bunch of really
fun stuff that happens immediately so
you don't have to wait all the way until
december for those bonuses to kick in so
go check it out really appreciate the
support i'm curious to hear your
feedback and if you have questions for
me i'll answer those in future editions
of evan
book so let's get to your questions from
last week first up is a know who wrote
in the say congratulations on the almost
3 launch Evan I'm excited too also
thanks for commenting on my comment as
you guys know you guys are the lifeblood
for me I love seeing your comments and
I'm in the comments pretty much every
single day responding to the ones that
are flagged for me and that I see on my
own so you guys are the lifeblood for me
like I you're part of my morning routine
I wake up and see the impact that I'm
having it makes me come alive and so big
huge thank you to you guys for leaving a
comment so I have something to reply to
next up Natalie good luck
congratulations I can't wait to get my
copy so excited it will do so well and
you will impact the world surely really
appreciate that Natalie there's been so
much work that's gone in especially in
the past week and a big shout out to j
reyez who's been working night and day
to help me get the landing page lined up
it's been so crazy that I can't even
articulate everything in the book yet
that will come in the coming weeks
getting used to talking about it i'm
just still in a state of shock and
overwhelmed that we're actually it's up
and live and you guys can check it out
so yes i hope it has a big impact and
thank you for your support in picking up
a copy next up as much weird idea to
take that clip with your response about
your non-stop content out into a
separate video love it it's amazing one
of your best rants woot so this one's in
reference to there was a comment that I
responded to and went a bit of a rant on
about why I produce so much content and
it was buried in the middle of a long
video I said I'm gonna pull that out and
make it its own video and just you know
just a lesson for you guys too sometimes
you make amazing things but it's buried
deep inside something else and most of
your audience or customers may not know
about it so pull it out make it visible
make an important as an example with
Toronto dance salsa one of the things
that we do is learning salsa can
sometimes be a challenge so we don't
teach it at the beginning the first
class you learn is merengue which is
easy to learn you don't worry about the
footwork as much it's just about the
Haynes and what you're doing and so your
ease and people into it it's like it's
the candy it's something that's super
easy to digest and then you can get into
the harder stuff and so if you've
created something but it's buried
somewhere else pull it out so it's easy
for people to digest and get to know you
in what you're all about and then you
can hit them with the harder stuff next
up is let passion burn would love some
info on your process of writing the book
let passion burn I would recommend you
go back and watch all 59 other episodes
of this series because that's exactly
what I've been covering every week it's
a specific question though that you want
answered after watching some of those
let me know and I'll do my best to
answer you in the future video cleat
Tahiti is writing in hello thanks for
answer my question about if a kindle
version will be available do you have a
price yet for each version regular and
deluxe the pricing is all set up on the
website again it's in the description
and will link it up in the video too
right now the full regular price is
twenty-six dollars because it's on
pre-order there's a discounted price and
then if you do volume deals with tons of
extra bonuses the price per unit drops
even more so depending on where you're
coming in app the individual price you
just bind one is around nineteen thirty
1950 depending on where you buy it from
it kind of changes been on promotions
outside of my control but then if you're
buying 10 25 or other multiples the
price drops significantly so check out
the link and then why don't you think
that rhymes check out the link let me
know what you think I like it new future
builder truly excited for pre-launch
you've been putting in the work and
deserve the success and impact that you
want I can do some early xmas shopping
too that actually was an interesting
part of the conversation the initial
launch was supposed to be in January
next year and I wanted to have it a
little bit sooner one because I don't
want to wait more like how long has it
been I want to get this thing out and
people saying seen the impact it's going
to have and to because it's December
then it does allow for some Christmas
shopping I wanted to though also how
things that you can get right now so
some of the bonuses will be you can get
coaching with me they're just one call
or six months of coaching access to my
personal email to be able to ask me
questions and be my priority inbox for a
while they'll be shout out so they'll
give people on the YouTube channel
randomly at the end of videos a bunch of
different bonuses that you can download
immediately so it'll be a bunch of stuff
that will be out that you get right now
but the book itself will come in
December so hopefully you get the you
get the double hit you get the immediate
hit and then you get the hit that comes
in December next up Natalie Evan will
you have online discussions on your book
once launched so after we read it and
have comments we can discuss at some
point thereafter with question and
answering from you that is let me know
and thanks that's an interesting
suggestion Natalie one that I hadn't
thought of a community or group of
people who want to share what they've
been going through their experiences
their questions I don't know I don't
know how to do that it might be through
YouTube videos where you guys can share
and I can respond and that
comes what Evans book is about after the
launch it might be somewhere else might
be an offline kind of facebook group I
like the idea I like the idea of having
a support group that you can connect
with I tend to do everything on youtube
because our believe nation community is
so tight and solid and you guys already
come in turn on each other's posts and
encouraging each other so my natural
tendency is to evolve it to something on
YouTube but yeah if you guys have other
thoughts suggestions on that private
hangouts or whatever let me know because
i like that i like for that to happen
again we don't have we don't we still
have time until december it actually
comes out but really super curiously get
your feedback on that next up Nathan
where could i get it I'm from Toronto
Nathan what's up I'm from Toronto and
city it'll be available in all the book
stores will be available in barnes and
noble and here in canada be chapters in
the go one thing that's super important
the reason why they do preorders like
this is because barnes and nobles and
chapters in the big book stores they
want to see where people have interest
and so if they see a new book has a lot
of pre-order interest then they stock it
a lot more in the books in the
bookstores if you don't have a lot of
pre-order interest then then we only buy
one copy that gets into the store so
it'll be a lot harder to get available
so that's why authors do a big push
before a book launch to get as many
numbers as possible so that when it does
launch it goes into a lot of different
bookstores you're here in Toronto those
so you could also we could figure out a
day you can come to Toronto dance salsa
I shoot every Wednesday afternoon we can
do a signed copy and that should be a
lot of fun for anybody who's in Toronto
who wants to visit Toronto you can
comment on Wednesday afternoon we
usually film what are we filming like
1230 23 ish somewhere in there and get
your sign copy executed that's be fun
for people want to come visit next up
Abdul Majeed hey I mean you're always
talking in your videos about other
successful people why don't you talk
about yourself in your own business
first I want to know your daily routine
in your top ten rules and thank you so I
do talk about this a lot this entire
video is about my journey in my store on
the book in the end special series I
talk about things that happen in my life
and my businesses as well for those two
things about morning routine and top ten
rules I've already done both of those on
my routine and my fans put together a
collaboration of my top 10 rolls
you can go check those out so I try to
inject my own personality into it the
top 10 series is more just a famous
entrepreneurs the ents presso morning
series is the famous entre thought and
my take on it and then the lunch time
series is usually a mash-up of different
things it's our hangouts its interviews
that I've done it's my seven ways series
and so the top ten is the easiest way in
and the least Evan the ants presa was
like a mix and then the lunch time
series is mostly Evan so I find it's a
good balance and hopefully you enjoy go
check out those two videos next up is
Aaron hey I've been I'm working on
starting an interior architecture and
design business I've been counting an
unexpected challenge my customers can
more often than not only purchase my
services one time you have any advice on
generating work when I am necessarily
providing a one-time service in a
limited geographic area so since we
could talk about the book now one
understanding what you're all about
you're an architectural firm amazing
there's so many people that I can go to
what are you staying for what's your one
word what do you believe in if I can
clearly identify that you staying for
this and that is related to what I'm all
about then it's going to be a natural
fit example Toronto dance salsa we're
about family we're looking at bringing
in interior designers to help us with
this space and the instructions that we
had was we want this space to feel more
like family this is what we're all about
we have a really strong culture and we
want our space to physically reflect
that so what can we do in this space
from the floors to the wall so the
ceilings to the fans to the smell what
can we do here to make it feel more
family and so if you are an
architectural design firm that talked
about that stuff maybe we deal with you
if you are trying to build a home and
you want to whatever it is that you hold
true as your value if that matches up
then I'm much more likely to want to do
work with you addressing a one time
versus ongoing the way to solve that is
to create relationship with partnerships
so selling to customers one at a time
can be hit and miss right because you
don't know if you're going to get them
on board or not but if you can work with
alliances partnerships look at who is
also selling to that audience so you
know our real estate agents selling to
that or commercial real estate agents or
other lawyers or you know who else is
already targeting that audience and how
can you introduce yourself so when
they're getting dealflow they can
connect you to them and again leading
with your values how are you different
why are you so special and unique beyond
just the skills that you have what are
you staying for is a human being
doing it to your business will help make
you more memorable in stand out grand
apparel congratulations Evan will be
available here in the philippines that
is an interesting question it will be
available online so if you can order
from amazon you should be able to order
it to get there bookstores in the
Philippines I honestly don't know it's
really going to be determined by
pre-orders so people are pre-ordering
from the Philippines then it will be
available more in bookstores and it also
helps determine languages so if we get a
lot of orders from the Philippines and
maybe we translate into Tagalog if we
get a lot of orders from Spain which
means in Spanish and so on so the best
way to ensure that it's going to be
there is to convince your friends to buy
a lot in the pre-orders next up
jagannath rayon hi tell me how many
hours you work I don't know it's not
something I really super keep track of I
think more important than tracking just
number of hours is are you doing
meaningful work you know I want the work
that i'm doing a time that i'm doing i
wanted to count if i'm having a meeting
with somebody I want that time the count
I talk you know with my wife it's not
just about spending time together and
finding more ways to spend time together
it's the time that we spend together
needs to count right needs to be a
connection because if you're just
sitting on the couch together but you're
you're on your phones or computers that
doesn't really count so much more
important to me then how many hours that
I work and try to just create a schedule
around that is more the time that I'm
spending on everything should matter I
want to have an impact and so whether
its family friends business whatever it
is the amount of time that I spend in on
something needs to pay off needs to
impact somebody else need to have an
impact on me and not just kind of
coasting through life next up real name
is there an audio version yes there is
an audio version you can get in an
audible now you can get it now an
audible that's great to say there's a
few other places you can get a two so
wherever you buy audiobooks you can you
can buy it and it's ready to go for
pre-order for the bonuses you can only
buy one audiobook so if you buy one book
with us an audio book and ebook or
hardcover whatever you get a bunch of
bonuses but if you're buying in any
quantity as gifts and you want some of
the bonuses that are attached to that
like a call with me asking me questions
that kind of stuff you have to do it
with the hardcover version so you can
buy one for yourself and then the
extra bonuses are through the hardcover
next up Luke these oomans make it so
dramatic I like things to be dramatic
Luke it's how I roll so thank you guys
so much for the support last week a
bunch of you left comments saying
congratulations and good luck and you're
going to have an impact and I really
appreciate that a bunch we also wrote in
asking about audio versions and it's
going to be available so hopefully
answer that for you again it's just so
overwhelming all the work that's gone in
the past week I'm still kind of trying
to catch my breath and articulate myself
and how excited I am about what's going
on with the book so expect more content
in the future again happy to answer your
questions about what it's all about or
helping you work through the process
thank you so much for your support it
means a lot to me you can check out
again the links everywhere on the
description really appreciate it if you
have a question for me for next week
about the book about my process about
your business leave in the comments and
I will answer it for you next week thank
you so much continue to believe and I'll
see you soon